Trascrizione: Paola Cutillo
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Come siete arrivati qui, stamattina,
seduti in questa platea?
Sicuramente c'è qualcuno
che è arrivato con i mezzi pubblici;
qualcuno con la propria auto;
e qualcun altro, a piedi.
Ha compiuto una scelta,
un po' dettata anche dal meteo.
Bene: questa scelta così banale,
se si è una persona in carrozzina,
ad esempio come me,
è una scelta importante,
con un proprio peso.
Perché quando si è
una persona in carrozzina,
le nostre azioni, il nostro pensiero,
sono molto spesso legati a mandata doppia
con le altre persone,
con quello che generano le altre persone.
Compiere una scelta così di uso quotidiano
spesso è complicato.
Immaginiamoci, per un attimo, anche voi,
di essere seduti in carrozzina
e vi muovervi in un mondo ipotetico.
Molte azioni che compiamo
possono subire grossi cambiamenti.
Pensiamo, ad esempio,
quando troviamo qualche persona
che parcheggia l'auto
a ridosso della salita, o della discesa,
di un marciapiede.
Pensiamo, ad esempio,
quando camminando su un marciapiede
incontriamo delle biciclette
abbandonate in qualche luogo;
o ancora, ad esempio,
alla raccolta differenziata.
Una cosa importante per il nostro mondo,
per il benessere del nostro mondo,
è così limitante
per il mondo di qualcun altro!
E quindi, ci troviamo a fare
i conti con le diversità:
le diversità della vita,
le diversità di crociera,
di visuale, di pensiero critico.
Ci troviamo, quindi, a dover fare i conti
con una parola che sono certa che,
per il 90 percento di voi,
è una grossa novità.
La parola è abilismo.
Immagino che voi pensiate
che sia qualcosa di meraviglioso,
che abbia a che fare
con un'enfasi di abilità, di fare cose:
bene, l'abilismo è la cosa
più brutta che possa esistere,
e che può essere alimentata
da noi e dalla nostra società.
L'abilismo altro non è
che una forma di discriminazione:
e discriminazione molto grave,
al pari del razzismo e del sessismo.
L'abilismo è la considerazione
che le persone hanno
di avere a che fare, sempre,
con un corpo altrui abile.
L'abilismo è quella situazione
che mette in divario una persona,
secondo i crismi -
ad esempio nella società -
rispetto ad un'altra
che magari ha dei limiti.
L'abilismo quindi va combattuto,
perché essendo una forma
di discriminazione
vuol dire mettere in secondo piano
l'importanza di un'altra persona.
E noi non ci possiamo permettere
di decidere, a priori, questo.
Nemmeno se è la società a darci questo la,
e a darci questa abitudine.
È su questo, che noi dobbiamo combattere.
Ma dobbiamo anche sapere cosa vuol dire,
e qual è la sua radice,
l'importanza nella nostra società.
L'abilismo ha due forme conclamate;
l'abilismo può essere attivo
e può essere passivo.
L'abilismo attivo è tutto ciò che riguarda
la comunicazione non verbale,
la gestualità,
ciò che noi andiamo a compiere come azione
nei confronti delle altre persone;
mentre l'abilismo passivo
è quello che riusciamo più
a combattere, se vogliamo,
ed è anche quello più di uso quotidiano.
È il peso delle parole,
è l'importanza del linguaggio
che noi andiamo ad utilizzare
in qualsiasi forma di comunicazione,
scritta od orale.
Dobbiamo imparare ad avere a che fare,
con il tema della diversità.
A non imbalsamarci davanti a un'immagine
che non rappresenta, secondo noi -
e sottolineo: secondo noi -
la giusta importanza
di essere definita persona.
Dobbiamo smettere, quindi,
di dare alle persone
un'etichetta di scadenza;
e soprattutto, imparare
ad utilizzare le parole
con il giusto peso,
scegliendo quelle giuste misure
per non mettere le persone
in difficoltà, in estrema minoranza.
È importante sapere, e conoscere,
il tema delle diversità
per scegliere quelle migliori.
E ad esempio, in mano
io non ho nessuna penna rossa;
ma mi sento di darvi qualche consiglio.
È giusto non fare leva
su una persona disabile
usando proprio questa parola,
cioè mettendo in primo piano
ciò che manca rispetto a ciò che ha,
o il limite che ha
rispetto a quello che può fare.
È giusto dimenticare
tutto ciò che riguarda
l'aspetto sanitario, la malattia:
non perché dobbiamo
nascondere ciò che siamo,
ma perché non è quello
che caratterizza ciò che siamo.
È la cosa più facile, forse, da vedere.
Lasciamo "Diversamente abile";
lasciamo "Handicappato";
lasciamo "Mongoloide",
anche solo per scherzare
con qualcun altro;
e impariamo, per una volta,
ad essere consapevoli
che davanti abbiamo una persona
con una sfumatura diversa
nel nostro mondo.
E quindi, la cosa più giusta da dire
è "Persona con disabilità".
Al di là del linguaggio,
che è la cosa più facile,
sulla quale possiamo combattere
per migliorare,
perché mi sento di dire
che è proprio una battaglia.
Ma abbiamo le giuste armi in mano,
per portarla alla vittoria: basta volerlo.
Abbiamo anche un abilismo attivo,
che non è da mettere in secondo piano,
perché le nostre azioni,
in rapporto a più persone,
in un rapporto di comunicazioni
a più persone,
è determinante nel messaggio
che vogliamo dare.
È giusto, ad esempio, rispettare
la persona con disabilità
per ciò che rappresenta professionalmente,
per ciò che rappresenta
con un nome e un cognome.
E non andare a toccare
quello che può essere
il suo ausilio nella vita comune.
Nel mio caso, mi dà molto fastidio
quando qualcuno si prende l'onere
di spostare la mia carrozzina.
Certo, per aiutarmi:
ma in questo modo tu agisci
sulla mia libertà e la mia autonomia.
È bene domandarle, le cose;
anche perché nel momento
in cui tu vai a toccare una persona,
non vai ad abbattere la confidenza,
e non vai neanche
a prenderti, quella confidenza.
Vai ad essere una persona ineducata,
e irrispettosa di ciò
che quella persona rappresenta.
È bene però anche dirvi che, purtroppo,
le persone abiliste non sono
solo quelle "normodotate",
che è un'altra parola che io aborro,
perché credo che non ci sia diversità
per decretare un lato A, e un lato B,
nella nostra società.
Però è giusto per farvi capire
che le persone abiliste siamo anche noi,
persone con disabilità,
che pur di non sentirsi
un peso per questa società
tendiamo sempre a minimizzare
ciò che siamo e ciò che rappresentiamo.
Tanto da farci diventare,
per questa società,
una categoria marginalizzata, una nicchia.
Una nicchia che, però,
è ora che abbia voce in capitolo.
Vi svelo un altro segreto:
la disabilità non riguarda solo le persone
che già si trovano in una condizione.
Non riguarda solo le persone
con una disabilità full-time -
come la mia, ad esempio, dalla nascita;
ma la disabilità riguarda tutti noi,
prima o poi nella vita.
Pensiamo per esempio a chi si rompe
un braccio, o una gamba:
per quei mesi, voi siete
disabili tanto quanto me,
e voi avete quasi tutti i miei bisogni.
Quindi, è giusto far entrare
nel nostro giardino questa tematica,
perché prima o poi avremo a che fare
con il mondo della disabilità.
Solo certa che qui, oggi,
vi ho dato un po' di novità,
vi ho fatto uscire da quella
che è la quotidianità,
e l'abitudine che abbiamo di relazionarci
con una tematica che, forse,
pensiamo non ci appartenga.
Bene: in un mondo
che ci vuole tutti uguali,
e ci vuole universali,
io credo invece che è giusto pensare
che al mondo ci siano persone diverse.
E prenderli non tanto di esempio
come fossero eroi conclamati,
perché per esempio non c'è
nessun mantello dietro di me.
Ma è giusto essere consapevoli
che le diversità di ogni persona,
chi più e chi meno,
chi più visibile o meno visibile,
devono essere un punto di partenza
per invertire la rotta
di questa società che va troppo veloce,
e non ha più tempo
di affrontare le persone.
Ma soprattutto, è giusto
che, attraverso questo scontro,
voi siate consapevoli
che la diversità di una persona
potrebbe essere il punto di partenza
di una nuova forma
di comunicazione, e di dialogo,
che va a finire nella parola "Futuro".
Grazie.
(Applausi)